Voiceover:The first thing
I want to do in this video
is given the information
given about this triangle.
Figuring out the unknowns,
figuring out the length here this value a,
figuring out this length in orange, b,
figuring out the measure of this angle
which we'll call alpha in
figuring out in radians
and figuring out the
measure of this angle,
right over here in blue
that we could call beta.
I encourage you to pause the video now
and given the information that we have
try to figure out these unknowns.
Assuming you've given it a try,
so let's see what we can determine.
We know two of the side lengths
and they're the same, they
both have side length two
and they've given us one of
the angles right over here,
this yellow angle has a measure
of pi over three radians.
One thing that jumps out of me
is that this is an isosceles triangle.
An isosceles triangle has two sides
that have the same length
so this side is congruent to
that side right over there.
That means that the base angles,
the corresponding base angles
are also going to be congruent
and that's just because
this is a property of isosceles triangles.
These two are congruent
so the two base angles
are going to be congruent.
That means that beta is also equal to
pi over three radians.
This is also beta is also equal to
Now let's think about ...
Now what else we can
attempt to figure out.
Well if we know beta is pi over three
and we know this angle in yellow
is pi over three radians,
we can figure out what
this angle over here
in white is
and I don't know, let's call that angle,
the measure of that angle let's call it x.
If we're thinking in terms of radians
x plus, this angle plus
pi over three radians,
plus pi over three radians,
this is the sum of the
interior pi over three.
This is the sum of the interior angles
of this larger triangle right over here,
they're going to sum up to pi radians.
If we're thinking in degrees
it would be 180 degrees
so those are going to
sum up to pi radians.
What's x going to be
and this one you can
almost look straight at it.
You say, this is going to be pi over three
but if you want to solve a
little bit more systematically
you can subtract these two from both sides
and you get x is equal to,
I'll rewrite this orange
pi is three pi over three,
this is the same thing as
pi, minus pi over three,
minus pi over three,
which of course three pi minus pi minus pi
is going to be pi over three.
These angles measure is
also pi over three radians.
Now that's interesting
because these shows us
that this is actually
an equilateral triangle.
All of the sides, when all of the sides
have the same angle measure that means …
when all the angles have
the same angle measure
that means all the sides
are going to be congruent.
If this side is two, this side is two
then that means that this
entire side right over here,
this entire side right
over here is equal to two.
Now what else can we
attempt to figure out.
Well let's see
we know this is pi over three radians.
We know that this is pi,
we know beta is pi over three,
we know that this is …
If we're thinking degrees 90 degrees
which is the same thing as pi over two
so if we know these two
angles of a triangle
we can figure out what alpha is.
We know that alpha, let me write it here.
Alpha plus pi over three,
plus this right angle which
in radians is pi over two.
We'll do in white.
Plus pi over two, that's
this angle right over here,
plus pi over two are going to equal …
or the sum of the interior
angles of a triangle ...
Remember we're looking at
this triangle right over here
that's going to be equal to
if we thought in degrees it
would be 180 degrees in radians
it would be equal to pi.
We get alpha,
alpha is equal to pi which
is the same thing ...
Let's see I'll find a
common denominator of six.
We can write that as six pi over six,
minus pi over three which
is the same thing as
two pi over six.
I'm just subtracting this from both sides
and I wrote it like that.
Minus pi over two which
is the same thing as
three pi over six
and that's going to be equal to
six minus two minus three is one.
That's going to be equal to pi over six.
Alpha is pie over six
so let me write that alpha is
equal to pi over six radians.
This over here is pi over six radians.
Now what's interesting about that
is that shows that alpha is exactly half
of this pi over three radian,
white angle over here.
That has measure angle at alpha
and this one also has alpha,
a measure of alpha radians.
Pi over six plus pi over
six is pi over three.
Now what's interesting about that is
that gives us confidence
that this thing over here
is going to be bisecting
this side over here
that this length
is equivalent to this
length right over here.
We are bisecting this angle
and so when we get to the other side
and this is an isosceles triangle,
we could actually now prove
that these are congruent triangles
that you have a side, an angle and a side,
side angle side.
This side corresponds to that side
so these two sides need to be congruent.
Now because these two sides are congruent
we know this has length b
then this has also length b
so we know that b plus b is equal to two,
or we could just say b is equal to one.
Now we could use that
information to solve for a
using the Pythagorean Theorem.
This is a right triangle
so we could say a squared
plus b squared which is one squared
is equal to two squared,
or we could say, let's say a squared
is going to be equal to
two squared minus one
so it's going to be equal to three.
I just subtracted one from both sides
and so we would have a
is equal to the square root of three.
If you remember your
special right triangles
from geometry class your
30, 60, 90 triangles
you'll recognize that this is one of them
but instead of calling
it a 30, 60, 90 triangle
we could call it a pi
over six, pi over three,
pi over two radian triangle
but it really is in degrees 30, 60, 90
and we see it has a properties
of the 30, 60, 90 triangle
where the shorter side
or the side opposite the
pi over six radian angle
has half the length of the hypotenuse
and then the longer non hypotenuse side
is square root of three
times the shorter side,
the side opposite the 60 degree angle
or the pi over three radian angle
has the length of square root of three
times the shortest side.
Just like that we were able to figure out
all of the missing information in this.
Now given that, what I want to do
is figure out what the
sine, cosine, and tangent
of alpha actually are
and I could have done it for alpha
or I could have done it for beta
but I'll just do it for alpha
and actually I'll leave
it as an exercise to you
to do it for beta.
Let's figure out
so the sine of alpha
and I encourage you to pause the video
and try to think of what this is.
Well the sine of alpha is the same as
sine of pi over six,
and remember Sohcahtoa definition.
Let me do Toa in a different color.
Sohcahtoa.
Sine is opposite over hypotenuse
so for this angle right over here
the opposite side is one,
so it's equal to one over the hypotenuse,
one over two.
Sine of pi over six is one half.
Now what is cosine of alpha
or what is cosine of pi over six?
Well cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse
so the adjacent side to this angle,
that's not the hypotenuse,
it's square root of three
and the hypotenuse once again is two.
The cosine of pi over six
is square root of three over two
and then finally for the
tangent of pi over six,
we could just take it
to sine over the cosine
or we could say it's the
opposite over the adjacent.
The opposite is one,
the opposite angle to alpha is one
and the adjacent is square root of three
so it's one over the square root of three
and if you don't like irrational
numbers in the denominator
we can multiply it by
the square root of three
over the square of three
to get square root of three over three
and we are done.
We have figured out a
lot about this triangle.